[Music]
about 10 years ago my girlfriend at the
time had an incredible collection of
friends i loved her but i really also
loved her friends and one of them was a
man by the name of kent kent was a
boyish uh almost cherubic looking
man who was very stylish he was kind of
like uh tennessee williams heroine
and mixed with the cheshire cat yes yes
good addition
and he talked like this and i'm not
exaggerating and at one point i had done
several movies in a row and i was in
need of a brag
i was in need of uh well the point was
that i i had to go also a brag i guess i
had to go to like you know premieres and
stuff and um and i it's important to
mention that he was a stylist yes we
haven't mentioned that yet have i not no
i said he's a friend of the woman you
were dating all right i left out the key
pieces
sorry
yes and i was in need at the time of a
stylist uh but i know nothing about
fashion so
who better to ask than kent he had
picked out some clothes for me and
included in them was this tie like thing
this accessory that i couldn't figure
out i said well ken what is this he said
oh jl it's an ascot and i sit in ascot
that seems
is that in fashion is that like and he
said not yet but it's coming back
and so he convinced that that was all it
took um i just trusted him implicitly
and i wore it uh and it never came back
the ask yeah scott kent was wrong and
now there's there's an era of photos of
you and ascot so
many and there's one of me too that's
right next to me maybe it trickled off
into me
are you wearing an ass yeah a gold one
it's so embarrassing
anyway thanks ken yeah but he was the
best he is the best
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is at
currently my ascot list brother
who has his hands in his pants
on my hips yeah i know
your hands are cold yeah it's a little
chilly in here thanks for sharing though
it's um
well be weird not to say that i'm
looking at you putting your hands down
your pants uh when you say down your
pants they are lies it's heading to the
genital area they're on that's very
misleading they're on your hips
just keeping warm against the body sorry
uh it is a kind of um rainy cold day
here it's a hand in the pants kind of
day
speaking of hand in the pants our guest
today
uh
well we're talking about kent this just
lovely you know how people say that word
use that word unicorn to describe
somebody who's very unique oh i thought
you were going to stay lovely
it's weird to hear you use that word to
describe someone well i've heard other
people use i've seen other people but he
is lovely he he's you're not wrong he's
like a human he's a unicorn and he's
he's got such uh people over sorry
interrupt people overuse the term
universe these days totally i think it's
appropriate though it applies
yeah um but i remember once my
girlfriend caught him i think we've
actually talked about this she caught
him
uh in her [ __ ] this big closet this
walk-in closet and she would catch him
trying on her gowns and certain dresses
and stuff oh my god you got me you
caught me he had so many funny like
catch phrases and my favorite one was he
would say
i'm just saying
and he would then go on to say the most
like wise
funny uh
just unique thing you know such a way
out why are we talking about
well another similar type of person
similarly lovely and
odd and
funny and unique quirky what i don't
know you know all these words can apply
is our guest today he's an actor but
he's so much more than that his name's
leslie jordan
leslie is somebody whom i i think we
both have been aware of for a long time
as an actor i would say nearly my entire
life yeah because he's ubiquitous yes
well starting in the 80s he he's been on
tv shows he pops up on tv shows
uh all the time
it's you'd be hard-pressed to to watch
uh to be a tv viewer and not know who he
is yes first it's when you see him
because he has a very
unique look he's very short as we'll
talk about i think he said he's four
foot eleven
uh and he just has such a wonderful
gentle voice this son and a very thick
southern accent he's from tennessee so
uh
he's just one of my favorite performers
and now he's one of my favorite people
because i've gotten to know him a little
bit
uh doing this interview and i was i was
so grateful for that my friend also
friend of the show max greenfield texted
me a couple weeks ago now and he said
you gotta follow leslie jordan on
instagram
and i immediately did because i trust
max and a sense of humor and uh i've
been i'm so grateful that i did it's
brought me so much joy during this
quarantine there's a great um malcolm
gladwell book called the tipping point
basically it's about trends and
and it talks about why things
become
popular sort of explode into popularity
right it goes from like it's sort of
obscurity to and then there's a tipping
point and then there's a waterfall of
popularity or success in some way yeah
uh and this happens
as i've been overusing
yeah um but this tipping point i think
it's it's accurate to say
he it happened to our to leslie jordan
in the last few weeks it's a perfect
example of that yeah because he went
from having
you know a modest following i'd say on
instagram a few hundred thousand people
too just in the last few weeks yeah now
he has millions of instagram followers
it's it's become such a trend and to put
it in perspective i i've been doing
instagram for almost a year now
and i started with you know a couple
hundred whatever and i'm up to like
three hundred thousand which is really
exciting this is not a humble brag i'm
just
uh perspective leslie also started a
year ago he started with the same amount
couple hundred uh and now keep in mind i
did instagram for the show and so every
week as you know if you follow me i'll
i'll post somebody that gets to the show
and sometimes they'll repost it and that
gives you more followers and stuff but
leslie just kind of films himself it's
all just him he just talks into the
camera and within a year he is up to
like three and a half million followers
but i would say
more specifically it's the last couple
of weeks it is it's the quarantine thing
i would say
the quarantine has produced two massive
things
did you see that no you spilled i got
all over the place oh god
sorry sorry that was a good point you
were getting i would say the quarantine
has produced two
two huge things one the tiger king which
we've talked about and two leslie jordan
on instagram
he's a phenomenon on on instagram during
the quarantine specifically he's an
instaphenom you know i almost said well
they're very different
but
there are in the venn diagram of those
two people there are a few similarities
um
and i'm not just talking about the fact
that they're both gay they are both
there's a certain uh
eccentricity of a southern eccentricity
i would say that they both possess not
to alienate our southern listeners
no alienate
no embrace um
they're both fascinating characters i
would say obviously that leslie is
on the other end of these benevolent
spectrum he is such a gentle sweet soul
it if you don't know who he is or who
we're talking about it you should
probably pause this now and go to his
instagram just for some context because
yeah it's it's hard to explain why he's
so entertaining you're right um so
i think we should let the interview
speak for itself yes we'll give you time
now to pause it yes and also just a
little
heads up um this interview was done
remotely because obviously we're all in
quarantine and leslie is in uh tennessee
chattanooga chattanooga he's near mama
he's near his mom and we're in
connecticut so near our mom yeah yeah
and we had some technical issues with
the connection and there were a few like
some glitches there like
as he's talking about it's a
so if you we're trying to
figure the glitches out for the next
interview we do um but please bear with
us yeah okay uh so
it will hopefully will iron this problem
out moving forward yes but until then
here is a slightly glitchy but very
entertaining very funny and fascinating
uh leslie jordan
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
it's so nice you to do this i'm so
excited to talk to you thank you
max greenfield is a mutual friend of
ours he's the one that pointed he said
you got to follow leslie
um how do you how do you know max first
of all did you guys work together we did
the same episode of will and grace he
was co-starring as deborah messing's
boss
and i was doing my little recurring
thing as beverly leslie um right karen
walker's best friend
anyway we started talking
and it's the craziest thing because we
just really hit it off
and then he invited me over for dinner
one night and i didn't know who his wife
was
and his wife is sanchez greenfield who's
had a casting for fox
as i left to go to his house they were
cutting a deal for me for the cool kids
this series i was going to do for fox
and my agent said don't disappear you
know how we have to go back and forth
where are you going to be i said i'm
going over to um max greenfield's house
he goes his wife is who we're
negotiating with
and there was charlie whose last name i
don't know he's real big over at fox and
chess and they said welcome to the fox
family and that's how i knew i got the
project and was that from uh your
reoccurring role on will and grace did
that have anything to do with you no
they were casting this part
uh the character's name was sid
and he was a 73 year old straight jewish
man from brooklyn
perfect
and you thought that's me
and
max said at three o'clock in the morning
now he tends to exaggerate like me he
makes up stories
he said at three o'clock in the morning
he was looking at that script with his
wife and he said you know who you should
read for this
his name is leslie jordan tested well
and so they called um
charlie
who was producing it who produced oh i'm
my mind's going you know charlie um from
um
oh charlie charlie from all the boys
over there he's always studying
philadelphia charlie charlie day
so max called charlie day at three
o'clock in the morning charlotte said i
don't know who that is and max said
just
he's the right one and then charlie told
me later on that when i walked in they
saw the series because it was originally
the cool kids was gonna originally be
three guys
older guys who grew up in brooklyn and
they're they're now the cool kids and
they rest home
together oh
they're all casting um
greer
leslie that's interesting have you
uh it was such a different type had you
done a role like that i mean when you
first heard that it was a new york
jewish tough guy well i walked in and i
said look i'm gonna put a different spin
on this i didn't try it all
okay okay okay i should try it all many
years ago there's a wonderful director
named sam weissman he went on to direct
the uh
mighty ducks
and he
cast me in this part as ralph short the
shortest member of the fbi in the
history of the fbi and he just sat me
down he goes now listen you carry a
certain kind of baggage it's not going
to work
and if you could articulate
what that exactly means what he meant by
that how would you say that he meant
butch it up you're too young
you're too good
he said that's not gonna work with this
character so i pushed it up which was
kind of hilarious
i can't remember what show that was on
and i said did i pull it off and these
were my friends in kansas they said no
the minute you walked on the screen my
friends that didn't even know you said
get a load of her
well you know i have a friend named kent
who is very um
i mean he makes you seem like john wayne
he's very flammable and and whenever he
would try to butch it up it would come
off
he would do this kind of slow southern
thing
it was the strangest thing i had agents
years ago
you know people think oh well what was
that like in 82 for a year
well you know what it was very wink-wing
come on we you would go out to the gay
bars at night you see every casting
director in town you see producers but
then during the day my agents would call
and say listen
feet on the ground
voice in the lower register keep your
hands
at your side maybe sit on your hands but
it didn't work
no it didn't work it never worked well i
want to hear what that what would that
sound like leslie because your voice is
so
unique and identifiable as well like you
said it sort of comes off like a dumb
redneck
try to
do it it's just not oh it's just so sad
but that's what you would try to do per
your agent's request because in 1982 i
imagine there weren't there certainly
weren't gay gay roles in mainstream
things uh i talked about this with
morocco the other day they had there
were characters of the nands there were
nance characters there were zany's they
called them
um
but
were those how would they describe the
roles that you would be going up for
back then we got minty a lot we got
mama's boy a lot yeah he's kind of like
a mama's boy he's a little slidy he's a
little this and that and i would just go
is he gay or what no then just no
come on but it was very
weak wink yeah interesting and and
that's when you came to la right leslie
in 1982 you moved from chattanooga
listen i got a degree
from the university of
tennessee
at
chattanooga
from the drama department where they set
me down and they said oh mr jordan
please before you go to hollywood learn
how to pronounce your degree because i
would still say they either
i got a degree
and i got on a bus my mother sowed
twelve hundred dollars into my
underpants
i'm not making this up and i took a bus
the old bus station used to be one block
below hollywood and vine it was that uh
day-long prey
and bond
and now it's the bus station no it's
mcdonald's it was the bus station it
wasn't even
it was like trailways or something i
literally got off that bus with a
suitcase wow i've never heard it
pronounced so beautifully day long pray
long pray we say de long pray
wait but leslie how did she sew the 1200
into your underwear i'm guessing it
wasn't a quarter
you know i'm i'm making up selling it
she pinned it right there so that i
would have it you know people don't
understand in 82 if you needed cash you
had to have cash you got ptm machines
really you don't understand on friday
you went to the bank yeah and you
withdrew your cash for the weekend yeah
you know you could sometimes write a
check to the grocery store you know if
you really really needed to drink that
night right like in the big lebowski
was was your mom leslie was she nervou
was she supportive of you going because
that sounds from chat i found a letter
not too long ago i got here on
valentine's day and i have twin sisters
they're 22 months younger than me my
mother wrote the sweetest letter she
said if things don't work out you can
just know you can always come home to a
standing ovation ah
wow that's really sweet they're so
supportive uh you it i'm there right now
i'm in tennessee right now that's right
down my mother's 85 and and i was here
for like business and i thought you know
what
this is gonna something's gonna happen
here and we're gonna have to stay and
i'm gonna stay here wow so i rented uh
this beautiful little condo here that
i'm in it's about 10 minutes from my
mother's because it's a dog and pony
show over there in what sense well
there's just a lot of drama i don't know
there's a lot going on i can't explain
it yesterday there's seven cats oreo got
a uh uh my sister said she's straining
she's straining to pee i said no she's
not she's trying to poop my sister said
no she's trying to pee she's straining
we took her
on a sunday during the lockdown oh god
now i've got to go there today and find
out because it's my credit card but
my sister's real good at oh it was no
big deal just some blood work you know
it's a grand it's a grand i know it's a
dream
so it's like oreo
sorry arroyo i don't know if it's worth
it it's trying to pay i can't you know
yeah
[Laughter]
so that's nice leslie you're able to be
close to your you must be nervous about
your your mom i mean 85 i'm nervous
about my own parents i am but she is so
she's such a stay-at-home gal oh good
she doesn't go i've never met my
mother's the baby of about seven
children and i don't know what that's
about but my mother she has such a
wonderful ability to entertain herself
well that's really coming in handy now
she does puzzles she does this and then
it's time for this and it's very you
know all day long don't have to worry
about her well leslie
not knowing you very well but you strike
me as somebody who got that from your
mom you seem like you're very good at
entertaining yourself and in turn it's
entertaining the country
does that come naturally to you do you
are you always kind of
making up little things in your head
i've always been like bass yes and baton
twirling yes that
i didn't know about intro uh in
instagram until yeah when i was on that
show with max richards wife in fact it
was all of her publicity girls and all
her casting girls that would say to me
post it and i'd go what post it what you
just said post it and i said i don't
know so they set me down they said
you're not on instagram i said no this
is not even a year ago
so i went on instagram and i got about
20 000 followers and i thought
and they go that's nothing keep at it i
said no 20 000.
yeah and then megan malali reposted
something of mine from willie grace bam
i said 80 000 followers and it was like
that until about two weeks ago and i
don't know what happened yeah what was
it don't know what happened well because
i around the time i started it was max
told me to look you up and to follow you
on ins and and so i did and i think you
had a cup you had like eight or nine
hundred thousand followers and
and uh as soon as i started watching
your videos i understood why there was
something so
there was obviously so funny and but but
the stories you tell are are so
compelling and there's something
comforting about about it but then a
week later i looked and god it was up to
two three million
and it happened like in a week 3.5 right
yeah
so leslie
how does that feel does it feel like do
you feel like pressure now oh like these
things have to be
a certain quality
at all we've i've been approached
like i learned a new word how would i
not know the word monetize
monetize
i'm doing this for fun i'm doing this
for free
the day the lockdown ends
[Laughter]
for those of you listening leslie just
held up his two fingers and gave the uh
the symbol forget about some funny for
free uh well good for you it's it's so
fun to follow you also have a lot of um
a lot of well-known people follow you
and i'm wondering if you
even know a lot of these people like
like drew barrymore follows you
you didn't know that oh yeah i noticed
that drew follows you
and adores you
and i texted her about you and she said
she gave me all these great questions to
ask you
yeah
so
if you wouldn't mind these are from drew
i have to give her credit cause they're
such good questions um first she says i
love that he's encouraging journaling
right now
uh this is a wild time that people can
look back on and reflect have you always
journaled from the time i was 17 and i
journal i i not only journal i draw
pictures
i i order stickers from this i saw that
yes
yeah i'm a high school cheerleader stuck
in a 65 year old male body i just
i i'm obsessed with that when i was 17
but i also figured out that it when you
put
pen
to paper because see i write in long
hand it slows your mind down to the
speed of a pen and you get clarity
so back in the days when you know there
were
boys i had crushers on us and i'd ride
oh dear diary i love him
i come back to read
who was naked
isn't that funny it seems like a
different person doesn't it
this is a good follow-up was there any
other time in his life that he he
journaled that he's really proud of
because he cried
and if so what was that moment a moment
that you look back on
and cry reflecting on it probably
the day
i'm sober 22 years completely clean and
sober 22 years wow and there was an
unfortunate incarceration
i want to get to that yeah i've been
pulled over
for so many times for drop drinking and
driving which is just such a big no-no
and um i'm very charming so you know
sometimes they'd let me go
there was a wonderful lady at the um
hollywood uh
lock up the
i'd walk in and she'd go
baby baby baby
she said you got to put the plug in the
jug i know
i'm going to i'm going to get i promise
i'm going
i promise
there was a day though that i knew
the jig was up yeah you put the plug in
the jug
i they they had me and my agent was so
upset with me because i was on a tv show
called
um it was mario lopez and little bicycle
shorts pedaling all around venice
do you remember
no but i want to watch a bicycle cops
what was the name of it
uh it wasn't
grunt i was a drunk in the alley who was
crazy but they would come to me to ask
me about what was going on
and i would talk nonsense and then i
would hit one they go whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa back up what back
the antenna so you'd have to deliver
exposition
i was on that tv show and uh i was in
the pokey and i called uh i said
my for the first time my agent said uh
no
i i can't come get you
wow
and i thought what i've got to do number
two in this
it's in front of everybody
oh that's right because there's only one
and i can't do it i've held it for eight
hours you've got to get me
i'd i'd never be able to do that there's
no paper and i'm not
and this is number two after a night of
drinking
yikes
so he didn't come get me but his um
billy miller who handled me for years
and years and years i'm not with him now
but he came and got me out and he said i
he i was just chattering away and
he pulled over the side of the road in
his little silver miata i'll never
forget this he said will you at least
allow me my anger
i thought what crawled up his ass i
didn't get it but to answer the question
i went home and i would start a journal
i thought you know what the jig's up
yeah the gym is up wow
in fact you so how how long did that
last that period of your life leslie
where you were drinking and working and
it was and you were struggling with that
it was um i did 12 days for my
unfortunate incarceration
and then
they came out and said we're gonna let
you go we've got a robert downey jr we
got nowhere to put him that's right i
read that you shared a cell with him or
or well actually i gave him my bed he
was there for a little while
uh-huh but i ran into him and ellie the
bill he he didn't remember me in the
sale with him
but he remembered a letter i wrote i
wrote him a real sweet letter
after that because there was a kid that
was on our our uh um
cell block that had hiv and they were
mean to him this is back in the day he
said don't eat with him don't sit down
with him he's got eggs don't sit down
and i would sit with him wow and he'd
get tears that as i said he'd say you
don't have to do this i said oh yes i do
and so when i got out i wrote a letter i
was only one privy to robert's current
address which was
you know 152 pod a sale 13 top book i
can't believe you remember that r downey
jr and you can get anybody's booking
number i don't care how famous they are
you can call and get their booking
number and i got his booking number and
sent that letter and then four years
later i was on ally mcbeal and he kept
looking over at me and i'm i'm looking
at him
zip it because i didn't want him in
front of all those
you know
russia de rossi and and lester flock
everybody was on that show
and i didn't want him talking about me
being in jail so i kept him dude
zip it but he came
do we keep saying zip it to me if we get
high together
no 152 pounds sell 13 talk he goes oh
you wrote me that letter
wow
wow he remembered what he remembered and
i said were you able to help him because
they moved him but he said i did carry
that letter my entire incarceration wow
leslie that's amazing you you must have
known that period of time must have been
be i've heard from friends who went
through that who came of age during
the 80s uh gay friends of mine who said
they just
the losses they suffered were
you know unimaginable i i imagine
well you know it's so
my first thought when this happened the
current pandemic i thought i've been
through this before right but let me
tell you the good news
we came through after the aids epidemic
we came through that
and because we weren't getting a lot of
help from the government we couldn't get
anyone to pay attention
we took care of our own and so during
that period
i mean
aids project los angeles where you can
go now and get dental work you can go as
you can get anything done over there you
can go see the psychiatrist you can do
anything
we have project angel food that will
take you we took care of our own and i
was thinking you know what
now
the world as a community it doesn't
matter if you're gay straight black
white asian latin
we're going through this
as a community yeah and i think we're
going to come out the other end we're
going to come out kinder and i think
that we're going to come out more
willing to help one another
something wonderful is going to come
through this
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
she had another really good question she
says the way he sees the world from his
height
what is he seeing that others are
missing
i wonder that myself you were you always
uh short lesson were you as a kid were
you tiny
i was real tiny i was you know what
happened was
because i've i've
made up not really made up but i'll tell
people oh i was teased and isn't it it
i was a very popular kid you know
because i was funny and i learned to be
funny to keep the bullies at bay
so when people say what do you mean you
were teased there you you have this
secret and you also think any moment the
axe is going to fall so you're just tap
dancing yes yes yes
you're going as fast as you're like
like a rodeo clown
you're going
and then you know there's sometimes
where
even as an adult i figured this out if
i'm
with you and i don't you end i'll start
you know tap dancing making you laugh
and this and that and then i've said
myself okay you know you're enough
you're enough
you're enough leslie you don't have to
you know it's been i i tell you at 65
and a lot of it has to do with
years of sobriety because you go to
those rooms those recovery rooms yeah
and you you um you tell stories my
spiritual advisor said to me you know
what your biggest fear in life is leslie
straight men
i said well no [ __ ] you know it wasn't
exactly a picnic on the player he said i
want you to join an all
male recovery group and i said in west
hollywood and he goes no
no fear of those men
and i walked into this room with all
straight guys and i'm talking
yeah
hey man what's up hey bud hey boy yes
have a seat
so i sat there and i thought you know
what it's now or never and they said to
me does our new guy want to share and
point it to me
from walking from my seat i must have
looked like like you said john 1 awesome
[Laughter]
and then i took a deep breath and i said
i'm scared to death i'm scared of you
guys i'm scared you're gonna laugh at me
i'm scared you're gonna make fun of me
behind my back and i'm really really
really afraid
that you're not gonna accept me
i cannot tell you i had this idea that
straight men don't have fear
oh threatening what are you afraid of
and i'd hear them share about their fear
of women i think oh please what do you
mean fear of women well just to you know
they're and
but i i learned that night that
everybody everybody has fears everybody
has
so uh but but leslie scared you justin
at all oh good well i'm a little scared
of you
uh no i likewise leslie i i feel the
opposite of scared of you what would
that be
um i feel such a affection for you um
and and and part of it is because i've
seen seen you for so much of my life and
things and every time i do see you on
screen
you always play characters that make me
happy you you have such a a light on on
camera but that's very sweet thank you
but i i imagine when you were a kid
in chattanooga
it makes sense that you would be afraid
of straight people because
you know you're walking around with this
secret and
i i don't think
kids certainly gay people now have an
appreciation for how difficult it must
have been
uh what were the consequences of
if that secret were to come out when you
were a kid what would have happened to
you you know you couldn't even voice it
back then this was the 60s the early 70s
i remember the first time the only two
people that i could see on television
were i saw truman capote one time
come on johnny carson
and he was so
openly afraid and so assured of himself
i went in the bathroom and threw up
oh wow why i don't know i saw
that and i thought is that it
because there was something
even though he was so brave
yeah there was something shameful about
it something deeply interesting and then
of course you had on the middle of the
of the uh hollywood squares paul lind
wait
charles nelson riley and i
i recognized gay humor but i didn't know
what it was they would say paul
um what did the lone ranger call his
side kick and you know he'd go beloved
and i would just scream
i would scream but i knew
when when i saw truman capote i
i went to the chattanooga public library
and i checked out every one of his books
and if you read early truman capote it's
very wink-wink it's that
feminine kid that doesn't it's coded
and i read i hung onto that and then i
started reading tennessee williams i
knew he was
and i read this place and i knew what
skipper and brick were doing
i knew those veiled inferences i knew
what was uh
yeah oh yeah boy did i know and that
connected me you know at least gay kids
today have the internet there are
millions of ways in which they can gain
support i thought i was the only one i
really wow of course my struggle was
more uh religious also
very religious your family you were
southern baptists right yeah i've been
baptized 14 times why why so many times
because it never did take
[Laughter]
get baptized at revivals i'd get
baptized in church camps anywhere they
wanted
oh my god the last center come forward
better try this again
take two
leslie i'm sure a lot of that rhetoric
that rhetoric must have been very scary
that fire and brimstone and uh
specifically about
gay people back then they never overtly
talk in my church
you know like that like like gay people
or if a man lays with a man la la
[Music]
yeah
yeah and and did it help do you think
the kids maybe not picking on you i know
your humor must have helped but and i
wondered this about myself excuse me
because i was so small i was so tiny i
think that made me much less threatening
to the other
guys
do you i wonder if that helped with you
at all it did in in in um
but i was never
once do i remember i think if i had been
straight and wanted to date girls it
would have made a difference but i don't
remember ever thinking oh i wish and i
mean i'm tiny i'm like 411. i'm tiny
tiny
you know you're 411 now huh 411. oh wow
wow wow little bitty yeah i'm real fat
right now but i think everybody uses
everyone like a bait spot with arms i
don't know what i'll roll out of this
yeah i think you're allowed it during a
pandemic those are the those the rules
you're allowed to gain some weight
during a pandemic
uh but but you think if you had been
attracted to girls it wouldn't have um
you wouldn't have been
you weren't competition for other guys
with other guys you weren't competing
yeah i i've always thought because girl
women just love me i they they sent me a
breakdown of my instagram uh-huh i don't
know where they got that or why it's
important
my followers are like about
80 or 90 percent women oh
and you
and me yeah me and max greenfield
3.5 million female followers
and justin long
[Laughter]
it's the same thing
uh
drew also speaking of some of your
female followers also um wants to know
when he was a child
uh who when he was a child encouraged
him
i'd let him know that to be funny in
life was going to be a crucial thing
that's kind of what we're talking about
when did you discover that uh humor was
going to be crucial to your survival was
that on the playground i was always the
teacher's pet i used to go home with my
first grade teacher spend the night
isn't that weird i said my mother did it
she said yeah you should pack a little i
said but would i just go to her hat she
goes oh yeah she'd take you home she
just
she'd take you home and you spend the
night because you left her so much oh
but anyway i the first time there was a
wonderful acting coach in hollywood when
i first got here she's long past her
name was carolyn berry
she's the first one because i came in
there with a mustache i look like ron
jeremy
these big cowboy boots
and um
she pulled me aside one day and she said
well you will you listen
to me um
you're so funny and you're so endearing
when you're being yourself
and
you're not pulling it off honey you're
really
there's a way in which you can learn
just to be yourself in front of the
camera and um it took a long time you
know yeah it really did it took a long
time when i got sober uh the first
thought was my friend said to me and
you're not supposed to say these words
but he said you're a [ __ ] hating [ __ ]
ah huh he goes you and i said no no no i
i don't hate gay men come on i'm the
gayest of all but i don't particularly
care for effeminate gay men he goes
hello
and i'd forgotten that was the csc
during all those years of drinking
that
and so my journey into sobriety has been
a journey into my queer to into just i
can tell you i'm 65 years old i'm
perfectly comfortable with who i am what
i am what a journey you know yeah wow
i'm trying to imagine who you were and i
got a little glimpse into it when you
posted that uh your high school yearbook
photo
uh for for those of you the few people
listening who don't follow leslie you
really should but um a couple days ago
there was a video where you showed your
high school yearbook picture and
you look like such a little stoner and
you reference you were like i i think i
was i had just smoked a doobie or
something right before that picture was
taken thank god you're a little stoner
that that
real cute boy i can't remember his name
asked me because what i would do
you would you would smoke and then
they'd want to do a shotgun i pretend
like they were kissing me
[Laughter]
that was technically your first gay
experience
gosh
oh no listen i'm not asking you what was
i just wondering if that was
close enough at the time oh i knew i
knew i told my mother at 11 or 12. oh
wow and i didn't even really know what
sex was yeah yeah but i you know i knew
something was up
my dad was lieutenant colonel in the
army
wow my dad was a man's man and you know
and then he was killed in a plane crash
when i was 11. yeah there was a lot of
horrible time for a boy to lose his dad
but i also felt for a really long time
he may have been disappointed in me
because i wasn't good at sports and my
mom
has told me so many stories that honey
he had you know he he was a he was a man
with a with a son who was twirling baton
in the front yard
yeah
65 you know
yeah he was an amazing father
and
did you have other brothers leslie you
mentioned two sisters that's it just uh
uh
daddy bought me a bride doll when i was
three he told mother button and i i
wanted it i wanted a broad dog and
christmas eve i asked for it and mothers
went to my dad and she said
you're going to explain it to him
and the door shut she heard it
he scoured chattanooga tennessee and he
found me the most beautiful bride doll
it was life-sized to a three-year-old
mother said when i came down and saw it
i spotted in the form paid
i just paid
you were so excited you peed i paid in
the floor
so that's so leslie that's when you were
three
so he must have known
something was up
as well i think i don't think they even
equated it you know you just had a kid
that liked to play with dolls and maybe
it's a face or you know i don't know
yeah
but but did he ever express then they
put me they put me in um
camp
like the
camp for boys just to make sure
the boys
sometimes it was the baylor our school
our local school the baylor uh camp for
boys
and uh on uh awards day they were
sitting there and they were passing out
all the words they said here's to the
best you know archer here's to the best
um you know softball player mom's
appreciated kind of sunk
and stunk
they got to they finally they brought it
not ribbons a trophy
and they said and now we're gonna give
to the best all-around camper and this
boy oh my gosh made us laugh and i won
the best dollar okay
that's your dad had a lady i didn't
you know yeah he must have
but so he must have been proud of you i
mean he must have been proud of things
like that like that's my boy yeah that
yeah
and and leslie was he you say he was
like a real man's man but was he a large
person
very small five four maybe oh well he he
was in any sport that he couldn't play
he would manage it or you know
mm-hmm
so he loves sports he did and
he would try to tell me he took me to my
first
football game he said now son this is
the offense right and you see this is
the defense and i said um when did the
majorettes come out because that was
[Laughter]
son just focus with me
uh
was there did any of that
is there any semblance of that in you
that you
find yourself watching sports and
never okay
that was a that was a layup question
uh what
and do you so you still have strong
memories of him leslie oh very uh wow
very well wow
and
my uh my mom loves to talk you know
about him and make sure that we kept his
memory alive so did she ever get
remarried she did
we don't talk about him oh okay
he was a good man he was just uh
had a lot of money
so all of a sudden you know we were
thrown you knew how to monetize things
beautiful beautiful yeah but uh anyway
he uh
we don't
okay okay say no more uh and she and
she's down the street she's 10 minutes
away
how often are you able to see her are
you going over to visit at all
from a safe distance about one o'clock
i'm going stir crazy here and i go over
and i'll take uh food you know i'm
trying to support it's funny they tell
you stay in stay in but support
restaurants stay and stay in but there's
so many of our local restaurants that
are doing takeout and barely getting by
oh
we should mention
which is the best barbecue in the south
so i'll go up there and get them
sandwiches and things
the best bar because you're ever in
chattanooga tennessee
rib and loin folks chattanooga area
listeners um
hey who else do you follow on on
instagram leslie that people might not
know like like a you a couple months ago
you know who's fun to follow that that
uh
other people should follow
well i follow my my best friend her name
is caprice crying
okay my mother was tina louise
you remember gilligan's island yes
well i used to eat at the um
uh griddle on santa monica oh i love the
griddle
yes
this beautiful woman come in there and
beautiful beautiful
and i will talk and then she said to me
one day my mom's in town i'd love for
you to meet her and then walk
oh my god and that and they is that bob
crane she still looks fabulous her
daughter's name is caprice crane and
she's she's very clever
i was interested
i'm sorry to interrupt that's not bob
crane's daughter no no her dad was less
crying
who i also had a connection with because
he did the there was a point of hippie
poem called the desiderata
placidly amidst the haste and he was a
san francisco dj who recorded
with music back in the hippie days you
know you're cool
oh yeah well placidly i missed the hate
and one day she was talking about her
dad and i said i thought maybe bob crick
she said no last name but same as your
name leslie and i said
who recorded the dessert errata
she said yeah that's my dad
wow wow you know leslie i'm thinking
about your name now it's interesting
that you say you your dad was a real
man's man and probably wanted you
thought wanted a son that was maybe more
into stereotypical straight boy things
but it's interesting they gave you the
name leslie
and it was his idea and mother has no
idea where it came from really i mean we
think maybe you know the actor from gone
with the wind um
we don't know he came in and said they
had decided on brett i think b-r-e-t-t
which was also not very well and he came
in and said i want to name him leslie
and i have
his middle name leslie allen
and um he's alan
he was alan and um interesting but you
know what i have gotten from my dad is
my senses to humor my dad never met a
stranger and he was the funniest man on
the planet oh wow he's so funny my
mother is beautiful she's like she's the
prettiest she when i was little i
thought she was a fairy princess they
would talk about fairy princess i think
oh that's my mama but she said that she
was lying on her towel up by the lake
and a wooden chris craft boat pulled up
which was beautiful and my dad was on
the boat and my mother leaned over to
her girlfriend and said that's the boy
i'm going to marry
she was 19.
wow he jumped off the boat
and he told his buddy
look see that girl that's the girl i'm
gonna marry oh walked over and tried to
be funny he said you're a real girly
girl
aren't you you probably sleep under one
of those uh
what are they called in my mother said
a canopy because she's very bashful
and daddy said oh no no that's under the
bed
canopy
that's pretty good
well leslie you are such a nice
combination of both of those elements
[Music]
i know you have to go right um you gotta
go i just have some quick questions i'd
love to ask um
one last one from true she says if you
could meet anyone that would make him
weak in the knees who would it be dolly
parton dolly i tried to meet dolly she's
from my part of the country oh yes when
i was at the university of tennessee i
would drive
up to a pigeon forge long before she was
dolly the movie star she was uh what's a
country girl without a hay stack and she
had she pushed does towels or something
and she would perform at the high school
auditorium and i would go up there all
by myself and cry she'd sing jolene
and i tried to meet her
there's several times and then there was
a friend of mine that was going to write
a sitcom
for her she had an idea called heavens
to betsy this is a million years ago
before touched by an angel she wanted to
be heavens to betsy and she wanted to be
betsy
and she told my friend she said
there's this tiny little man that i saw
on murphy brown
and my friend said
golly that's leslie jordan
he is your biggest fan she said honey
i'm his biggest fan
oh my god we've never made it oh no
never mind
leslie if i can do anything i pray to
god this is somehow this is this will be
the catalyst for you to meeting to me
oh that'd be great i would love for that
for both of you um i'm surprised you
haven't now because over the years i
went to the hollywood bowl and i was
supposed to meet her and then she was on
jay leno and got stuck in traffic she
won't do her meet and greets afterwards
you know and so uh i went i went all the
way to dollywood for i gave up
some money for her imagination library
her daddy never learned to write till
the day he died he did an x so she
started a library and kids get a book a
month
it's called the imagination library and
it um she shows up at dollywood once a
year and i went up there i went away
and i knew she wasn't there i could tell
by her handlers and there was a dinner
for all the donors i knew i said she's
not here
and all of a sudden on the screen she
said for the first time in nine years
i'm stuck in los angeles oh
that's right
that's where you were
here to see you oh it's going to make it
that much sweeter than the two of you
you better have your family she probably
thinks i'm a stalker
you've met the family i've met all her
her sister fredo she was the baby with
the twin has a daughter named janna that
sings at opryland and does all the big
numbers
and
uh i went and got to go afterwards to
meet her and she said well you know this
is dolly's oldest brother and this one
and this they all work there at
dollyline dollywood oh really
oh god i love that um uh i know you have
to go see your mom these are quick
questions just a lightning round oh god
okay uh other than making amazing videos
what what well we've talked about what
you're doing during quarantine you seem
to be keeping very busy
you know what i do i get up every
morning take a shower and i put on my
shoes there's something about that i
have to put on my shoes put on my and
then i figure well what am i gonna do
well i'll sit here and read the paper
but i have got to get up and i also have
a wheel i don't put my pajamas on until
eight o'clock oh it's oh that's smart
yeah you know yeah with mother about
five i think i just wanted myself no i'm
not i'm gonna say i sit with
when do you get inspired to make a video
leslie is it just when something comes
into your mind and you think sometimes
in my head
or scripted it's awful awful yeah which
doesn't speak well of you know me on a
script this fall call me cat my brand
new television series
yeah yeah i have a big series
yes when is that coming out well we
haven't even shot it yet we were going
to do a pilot and then it's a or with
mayam bialik it's my ambialic and
cheyenne jackson kyla pratt and swoozie
kirk
oh
god
i almost said
it takes place in louisville kentucky
and swoozie is fancy she goes to the
races with hats on and she wants her
daughter to get married her daughter's
38 years old that's mine
when mayan takes her dowry and in spite
her mother who's allergic to cats she
buys a cat cafe
and i rank up the [ __ ]
that must have been a first oh that's
like a paul in line
it just has hit written all over so
we'll see yeah you never know
i can't wait um and and the producers
and the people who got you involved must
be extra excited about your new found
darling that created it with mayam and
wrote it she's just brilliant
yeah just this like oh my god
oh my god
it's great uh leslie what's your most
commonly used emoji would you say when
you're texting
i don't use them
probably that one with two hearts on the
eyes uh-huh yes yes
if you could be i think i know the
answer to this if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play
wrestling
okay
okay okay that's amazing perfect if
you're gonna watch one
okay okay that makes sense
uh if you could have one snack food for
the rest of your life what would it be
what snack food can you not live without
cracker jacks
okay okay
beautiful what's your favorite movie of
all time my favorite movie of all time
is called entertaining mr sloane
nobody's heard of it it's from a joe
orton play about this husband and wife
it's from the 60s and it stars barrel
reed and i scream all the way through it
and it's not completely a comedy
it's about mr sloane is this young
hustler it was very ahead of its time
young bisexual hustler that shows up the
sisters after him and she's aged and the
brother is very he's after him too but
he's of the military sort and
and then there's the f anyway
oh i got a screen entertaining mr slump
entertaining
joe it sounds very like lanford wilson
or like tennessee williams
yeah um if you could live somewhere else
anywhere else besides chattanooga and la
where where would it be probably um i
love uh middleburg virginia because it's
horse country i think i'll end up buying
a little pony farm there
i grew up with ponies
did she i had a show pony named lemon
drop
my friend i was saying well of course
you do yeah
yeah it's a that's a butch uh name and
animal to own
um
if if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
diamond martin
a batman
uh-huh and gail burnett okay
that makes sense and they'd all get
along too i would love to be there oh
would i be i'd serve you guys i would
happily serve you all um who's your
favorite muppet would you say
yeah that was my generation probably i
don't even know
okay i don't know muppets okay if you
could have one superpower what would it
be
um to
stop pain maybe but that's nice
uh if you could be one age for the rest
of your life physically uh an age that
you just think i'd love to get back
there i think 65 which i'll be next week
good for you oh next week yeah april
29th i'm gonna wind up this little
publicity tour on rachel ray oh nice
yeah you've been doing a lot lately yeah
on the view
uh
yes
and you've been doing it all from this
rented condo right here isn't that i got
tmz next week e.t
oh i don't know what oh
which golden girl do you identify with
the most dork blanche
who i know
oh i bet i bet i toured with ro a lot of
people don't know she lost a lot of her
money with i think bernie madhoff she
was 73 years old to go back to work and
so we hit the road and
she couldn't stand up because she had
bad back problems so we did sit down
comedy and i'd wheel her out
and then i would do
i would uh i would finish she would do
45 and i'd do 45. oh my god you know
leslie i'm surprised you've never played
truman capote in something you know i
did it it was a
it's a long story i'll i'll do it short
yeah they hired me about two years ago
to do
uh
warhol capote
and it was a play by uh rob ross about
the two of them sitting talking they
were very good friends when truman when
when andy warhol died they found
68 tapes that said truman and andy
warhead recorded every word they were
friends
since
um
uh truman came to new york to stalk andy
he wanted to illustrate
no not the opposite
and he came to new york to stop trimming
because he wanted to illustrate other
voices of the rooms
and wow i am truman was andy's dolly
parton
i am yeah
we
we rehearsed we went to um
to boston to harvard it was headed to
broadway we rehearsed at the american
repertory theater oh wow and what
happened was
truman i had
60 i had
i don't know 34 pages of dialogue
yeah
i couldn't do it
wow a week into a week into it was the
hardest thing i've ever done in my life
because truman spoke in a certain
dialect
truman and here's the thing truman
wasn't funny
and he wasn't a nice person he was a
vicious
person
huh and that anyway i couldn't be funny
they had a dialogue coach and i didn't
have breakdown but i was like finally i
just told him i said i can't do like
this is not in me
well it's the hardest thing as an actor
i've ever done and they hired um
uh oh what's his name to do it
my friend
i can't remember anything
was it the voice was part of it was it
the voice what kind of it and it was i
couldn't do it it's like yeah exactly a
lift
no it was
it's a yes so you should do it yes i
should have done it you you know
was it like this
it was a bit like this
um you should do it and max can play max
greenfield can be warm
max can be
well you know what i'm really itching to
do now leslie now that you mentioned
dolly parton is we have to have a night
with tess max
and and you where we go sing karaoke we
got to go to a karaoke bar oh my god
um that's my fantasy now um really
quickly uh the beatles are the rolling
stones do you prefer the rolling stones
okay dogs are
day one dogs are cats
uh dogs
and uh
this is i never know how to end with
this but um
do you still identify as a baptist you
still have any religious leanings you
know i wrote it's so funny i wrote a
book about it called my trip down the
pink carpet about which was supposed to
be funny stories about hollywood and it
became in many ways my spiritual journey
and so i wrote it so long ago that when
i go back and we don't write a book
about your spiritual journey because
it's evolving and it changes so much yes
and i i
back then i had heard carrie fisher say
this and i loved it
she said i am a very enthusiastic
agnostic who would love
nothing better than to be proven wrong
uh and so that
was my feeling because
of course my mother's just horrified
because i was raised in such a loving
baptist home
and they have very strong beliefs about
how you get to heaven in this net
but anyway i have to say i'm um i'm i'm
with carrie yeah yeah i'm with carrie
but see you know what i found out though
it's in the seeking that you can find
faith
you just keep an open heart and as you
wow you know so i i'll go to church i'll
go to temple i'll go anywhere you want
to take me and i'll take you know
i'll take away what i it's like a buffet
you know oh wow i can really use that in
my life that
under the few in front that i'm going to
leave
that i'm leaving exactly but this is
okay
well leslie if you were if you were part
of that spiritual buffet i i you've been
a stop on that buffet that so many
people are enjoying right now and and
you're giving so much
pleasure and and
warmth to a lot of people myself
included so i i thank you for that on
behalf of so on behalf of 3.5 million
women thank you and justin
yes oh and jason kennedy do you know
jason
no he's a he's my next one he's some
kind of e entertainment guy who's okay i
told him i said you're just too pretty
to be straight you're too pretty
you're too pretty
well like cheyenne you're working with
cheyenne jackson he's one of the
prettiest ones he's so pretty yeah
he's gay as me though
he really is oh yeah he's come his
gayness is comparable to yours
yeah
i find that hard to believe you hadn't
got him alone with his chest
[Laughter]
ask him to do his character trolly which
i swears based on me cause trolley it's
like this great great big good-looking
boy with a baseball cap on backwards but
he opens his mouth and 50 yards of
purple [ __ ]
he's a great children and troy you
should have him
well i should well i i really like
cheyenne the other day i was doing this
little cooking uh video i've been
cooking a lot at home and um i just
found myself going like this and then i
put in the oregano
and i'm gonna add a little olive oil but
not too much i was like what
is that troy that's true um well i love
that character you should do a cooking
show with you
like that in troy
yeah oh i hope you would watch honey and
you promote it on you promote it on your
ig
um well leslie thank you i can't thank
you enough this was a real treat listen
thank you so much bye-bye
yeah bye i'll see you see ya on
instagram okay for sure
okay buddy
i'm still here don't talk about me okay
oh no i was about to say something nice
uh so great um
how do we turn it off
this might be the best part leslie
bye bye thank you
[Music]
so so that happened
oh that did happen and i am just tickled
to pieces that it did
how's that you know i must say
i admire your restraint during that
interview thank you i
i there were a few times where i had
like a little out of body experience and
i realized i wasn't i was tempted i of
course had the temptation to to do it to
do his voice for those of you don't know
christian's talking about my
uh my penchant for
imitating people to their face um which
which sounds mean but it's actually
i i think
it's just a disorder you have
it's motivated i think it's motivated
more by affection um when i'm watching a
movie or if there's someone with an
accent i have to
repeat what they're saying in that voice
so i did not do with leslie but part of
it too was no you did it a little bit oh
yeah just not that much just not nearly
as much as i thought you were okay
well it's it's difficult for me and
especially with somebody like that
because he i love his
doesn't he just one of the best voices
ever
you know people use this expression a
little too much too i think
myself included but i could really
listen to him reading the phone book oh
yeah and enjoy it yeah
it's hard to imagine a more
a pleasing fun voice to listen oh mike
albert abrahamson 14 92 cherry hill
terrace
which which
which partially
certainly partially explains his rise to
fame on instagram absolutely but it's
not only partially outside no no because
the content is very funny too but i
wonder about leslie and about our friend
kent whom we mentioned earlier
how
just how the level of awareness they
have for how unique they are and and
where their charm
how their where their charm resides
right i don't know
i don't know he's there there seems to
be an innocence about him yes there's a
there's a character when you uh well
about both of them but about leslie um
because when you talk to him about
uh monetizing this yeah this newfound
fame he has
and i just learned
yeah i believed him when when he implied
that he didn't set out
absolutely you know
get rich off this instagram family
absolutely it the whole thing struck him
as um and i also believe this that a
huge surprise and like a welcome one i
think he's having fun with it
um and i love that he was honest about
it and that's part of what makes him so
entertaining is his honesty he's just
he tells these great stories but he
doesn't have much of a filter and i
think people have been really responding
to that well that's also the
sober thing you know i've noticed on the
show
a lot of we've had a bunch of guests now
who are sober and who have
gone through a process to get sober
and
there's a there's a commonality among
all of them i've noticed yeah you know
there's there's a kind of
thoughtful
wisdom and honesty and openness about
them i think that's a huge because
they've done a lot of work on themselves
right and i can tell that he's done a
lot of work on himself and that he's
struggled and so much of that work
involves opening up and sharing with
others oftentimes with strangers which
is exactly what he's doing on instagram
and and his struggle specifically is so
complex i think
being
uh
a flamboyant gay
kid from a very conservative area
southern baptist southern baptist um
yeah he claims he he talked about having
a very macho father but the father
sounded
you know it's hard to tell but somewhat
supportive that he bought him a doll
when he was a kid but
but the only thing that matters is uh
leslie
was
scared of what you know he would think
of him so from his perspective his
father wasn't necessarily accepting who
he was so but again like complicated
life he's had but looking at it through
the prism of like history you know
that's
like you said relatively the father was
probably far more accepting uh and open
but who didn't like it but who knows
uh and my mom encouraged us she i
remember her buying me a cabbage patch
kid yeah and i remember you guys kind of
teasing me about yeah i'm sorry about
that we shouldn't have done that that
was uh
we were kids in the 80s um and there
were very specific gender norms
that that we grew up with but um
our mother encouraged it i think in part
because she
wanted a daughter yeah
yeah um and then in retrospect i i feel
like i'm ashamed of my behavior as a kid
because
now of course we live in such a
different time a much more open time but
like
who cares if you know boys are yeah well
you shouldn't dwell on no i did many
other things as a kid that i i'm ashamed
of um
but yeah you were really into that that
you were into annie and superman three
we've talked about that on the show
those were the two movies that you
watched obsessively that is a fact yeah
uh i did not know he was that short
leslie jordan
411 and we was funny you guys i'm 411
and you go
now
[Laughter]
he's had a great line he said yeah i'm
like a beach bald arm yeah
yeah he has great lines he's funny he's
funny yeah he's so funny he's so
yeah he should write something um
i mean he does that's what he does in
his videos
he's doing fine uh you mentioned
grillo's pickles again yeah uh and now
you're mentioning it again well i'm
hoping to get more pickles
not an ad he said with his hand on his
own pickle
uh on my hips
um reloads i would love leslie speaking
of monetizing leslie's monetizing
adventure he'd be able to monitor i mean
he could sell
me anything so
many things right now
yeah he could become a billionaire
advertising things he could sell uh he
could sell sand to a nomad in a desert
you asked him what sport did you ask him
what sport he would play and he said
wrestling one-on-one oh wrestling
wrestling one on one
[Laughter]
there's something cheeky about
gay men of that age
go with me on this there must well i i
really hope this isn't offensive but
there must be a sense of
real liberation
when it comes to being
uh open about their sexuality and being
able to express their sexuality you know
although with leslie it doesn't sound
like he
stayed in the closet for that long but i
do know
men of that age who are either one way
or the other either lean in to the
sexual innuendos or whatever or they
avoid it because that's just how they
they were for so many years yeah we
probably also should have mentioned
earlier that what he's what people maybe
most
know him from is will and grace that's
true that's i think how i know him yeah
but i had seen him in so many other
things he there was another actor a
couple actors one that comes to mind tim
i
can't say his last name he's published
last night he was in police academy um
very short there were certain like short
they would stand out because they were
short and um and they had
unique voices and uh and he was always
that guy i would always notice him danny
devito danny devito you know um
you know yeah he won and emmy i just
want to get this out he won an emmy
award for that performance in will and
grace oh wow probably should have
mentioned that i should have i did not
know that
that's wow uh he's an incredible actor
too he's a very believable funny actor
um
anyway he he's just been making me so
happy the last couple of weeks
so his uh his dinner
uh dolly parton
uh
midler carol burnett and him
oh
how badly do you want to go to that
i don't want to go to it because i would
be really nervous and all right in over
my head i couldn't what i i i would feel
like because i'm the fifth person at
this dinner party i would feel the need
to contribute something
and i and i know i really couldn't so
the whole time i would be i would try to
be thinking of something to say
something sassy and like but i would
want to eavesdrop on it yeah it would be
you're right you're right just so
socially it'd be intimidating because
imaginary the pearls that would be
coming out of all their mouths and i
don't you find it odd that he hasn't met
dolly pardon if dolly dolly pardon is
aware of him likes him he's made he's
gone to such lengths to try to meet her
that is weird and especially now with
social media you'd think the two of them
would have hooked up on
on instagram or something i know he was
also very excited
when you told him that drew was
following him on instagram oh was he i
didn't oh my god he was like what uh-huh
she is yeah well drew we should mention
is ken's that's how we know kent
oh yeah yeah i should maybe why say that
uh
but yeah she is and so drew has a v has
a real fondness um for
people like leslie and and uh
she yeah maybe my favorite part of the
whole interview was who doesn't i mean
was when you asked him
uh which golden girl he identifies with
and you were about to list them yes and
he just goes blanche
[Laughter]
really funny yes yeah there's a joke
that we look like he's been asked that
question every day for the last 30 years
yes yeah there yeah he was so ready and
of course friends with ru i knew rue
rue and i were friends of course i mean
uh let's read a letter okay great
this is from catherine subject is so
important dear justin and christian
every night during this crisis i fall
into bed and hope to find one of your
quarantine updates ah that's so nice if
there's if there isn't a new one i just
re-listened to the max greenfield
episode oh
yeah we've been talking about max he's
the best by the way speaking of funny
instagram videos stuff with lily his
daughter is so good
uh i'm sure you all are aware if not
check it out on instagram here sorry
back the letter here's my situation
during this crisis i work for a
non-profit that operates five buildings
of affordable housing for low-income
seniors as such we are an essential
service and don't have the option to
self-isolate well for the last six weeks
my days have been filled with calming my
staff and motivating them to continue
sanitizing every inch of our buildings
wear protective gear deliver meals and
not freak out as we take their
temperatures before every shift oh my
god
i'm also constantly communicating with
500 plus residents about the importance
of staying in their apartments god but
they are lonely and pretty stubborn yeah
each day i feel like i am willing the
virus away from our buildings and it is
and it is exhausting
as of this moment we have had no cases
but i continue to just hold my breath
i have a good cry on my drive home
stress eat and then go to bed i cannot
tell you how much hearing you and
christian helps me decompress
i love your banter and dry humor when
you hung up on jerry during his exit sex
i laughed out loud and then i realized
it had been a long time since i had
laughed out loud
so thank you from the bottom of my heart
for doing your part during this these
scary weeks
catherine that
is very very kind and
uh that's very nice very nice and i'm
you know i i we keep talking about this
but um
i i keep having these real profound
moments of gratitude and uh
i just had a wave of one because i
momentarily put myself in your shoes uh
very momentarily and i'm so sorry you're
going through that uh
and it just makes me feel so lucky and
grateful to people like you uh
god i can't imagine
crazy and and
grateful too that this dumb thing that
we're doing is any comfort it's scary
these old
folks homes i know they're the one
closest to where we grew up not far from
where we are now is uh experiencing a
pretty big outbreak there and um a few
people have died and a bunch of others
are sick and my friend's grandmother
lives there so it's all very scary and
um it's it's really brave and noble of
you to be doing what you're doing to
help them yeah so thank you catherine
and everyone
like catherine and
even people who are just staying home i
mean i i i know it doesn't seem like
much but i think uh for the greater good
it is going to have it's going to help
people like catherine get through this a
lot
more quickly and if you guys would like
to write in we love hearing from you
and we can be reached at life is short
at wondry.com so please write in and
thank you to our
wonderful hilarious
lovable gem of a person gem of person
yeah one of the
just one of the best and i like his
positivity and optimism about this
pandemic being over he he mentioned that
when this is over he thinks that people
are going to come together with more
kindness and he thinks the world is
going to be a better place and i know
sometimes it's it's hard to see that
right now but um i really appreciated
that optimism sometimes it's nice to
hear
that because it's like i said it's very
easy to
lose sight of it yeah that it's that the
effect that it's had um is that of a
resetting almost not just on i know
people talked about the environmental
effects that it's had but just on our
own
sociological
environment you know i i've noticed and
i hope this lasts i hope we
carry this on past the the um
during the the postcovid time but i've
noticed that people been saying
uh acknowledging one another more i
found myself doing it you know talking
more to strangers and you know from a
distance uh well not to be debbie downer
but the flip side of that and i think
the danger of that is because we're
being
um conditioned now to isolate with our
tribes whoever
those people may be
um my fear is that it's going to create
this sense of tribalism where
everyone else is like the other and is
unclean and
because there's there's a real strong
metaphor um thanks sorry yeah but but
let's uh let's go with leslie's version
of it because that's the one i prefer oh
man so uh thanks to leslie and
and and i want just thank him too for
for spreading joy during this time uh
instagram's been
to a fault sometimes i'm on it too often
but it's it's been a source of
joy and comfort and and uh leslie's been
a big part of that so
uh thank you to leslie to catherine and
everyone writing in
and everyone listening yeah yeah
we appreciate it's true we wouldn't be
doing this we appreciate your ears yeah
that's right uh
life is that's it right yeah and we'll
see you soon
and we'll check in in a couple days with
another quarantine episode
uh thanks for listening
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's produced by you christian long
and megan monaco senior producer is
michelle
lance audio engineer is sergio
enriquez executive producers are
marshall louis and hernan lopez for
wondering bye
[Music]
the fact he's able to improvise the song
hollywood
means that he has
right clever of course it's ridiculous
he's rhyming words
off the top of his head if he sang a
song as the character with no brain
hannah just didn't write terrible it
didn't rhyme it like barely made sense
there was no melody to it she's like
what are you doing he's just like i
would put sticks together
in a shape bad luck she's so funny and
then like the tin man like
laughs at like a little like
like poor kid getting robbed yeah he has
no heart it's like really no heart
and the cowardly line was literally like
just [ __ ] all the time the garlitly
line is cowardly it's the one that yeah
yeah
doesn't this guy look like a bachelor
like the turner classic movie yeah he
looks like um
oh joe yeah grocery store joe oh god
i wish that weren't in my brain speaking
of wanting a bigger brain
taking up limited resources in there
grocery store joe
you